how is everybody good to be here hey by
the way I just became an uncle again for
the fifth time and yeah you're right not
to collapse because because we don't do
anything being a parent that's hard work
but being an uncle is easy that's why
there's no like books about being an
uncle you know like nobody ever wrote
like what to expect when your sisters
expecting for example there's no uncle
magazine a lot of magazines about
parenting
there's no uncle weekly magazine board
an article P in that magazine is your
nephew out of control with drugs and
alcohol
well since it's not your problem here's
some weekend getaway I did pretty much
all you got to do when you're an uncle
just don't touch the kid inappropriately
that's pretty much the only rule if you
do that you're considered a reasonable
uncle being a father a lot more
complicated someone tells you they had a
bad father that could mean anything that
could mean he wasn't there for you
financially emotionally he didn'r to you
he didn't care for you but if someone
says the I had a bad uncle you know
exactly what that means there's no
ambiguity there right never have to ask
go why we see a bad uncle you know damn
well why he was a bad um you might ask
oh how often was he a bad uncle that
might come up or well where did he bad
uncle you you know that might come up
I'm from the 70s originally and
I lost my virginity in the 80s well I
didn't but I would have if they had text
messaging back then but that makes
things a lot eat in the old days you
want to ask a woman on a date you had a
caller on the phone and have what's
known as a conversation you know how
scary that was I call a girl up I'd be
shaking like a leaf I'm all nervous then
she answers I start to stutter I'm all
timid I'm like a week we could have
lunch or something if you're not busy
it was tipped but texting is easy I'm
like yo baby girl what you doing with
your fine self to shake that ass on over
here I will tear that up cuz you get to
my apartment I'm like girl you lookin
fine tonight she's like I'm standing
right here while you're still texting me
you ever notice Pete was sending a text
people are all obsessed with spelling
he'll send you a text with a typo and
then he can't just let it slide they
gotta send you another Texas second
later with the word spell correctly the
other thing I'm at a restaurant my
friend text me yeah I'll be there soon I
got to park the cat then the second
later I got a text asterisk
car not to me to brag but I had actually
already figured that out
I didn't think he was walking down the
street like yeah you can I leave my cat
here by any chance
sometimes you send a text the wrong
person right you ever do that that's
that can range in severity from no big
deal to your life is over as big an a
typo you send a text to the wrong person
you can't cover that up by pretending it
was a typo that would never work like if
you text it like hey my wife doesn't
even know we're sleeping together
asterisk be home soon honey for me the
worst time for me that I ever texted a
wrong person
I texted by mistake come over I'm horny
too my cousin Sheila I apologized like
sorry cousin Sheila that that was
actually meant for somebody else so uh
sorry it came all the way over here
Sheila the poor thing is so lonely you
know if I'm from the 70s
I'm 45 but sometimes I lie about my age
like just a second ago when I said I was
45 for example I'm actually 46 but you
lie about your age it's not easy cuz you
got to lie about everything
you know because you'll give your age
away very easy like one time I told the
girl I was 34 and I'm some Nirvana song
comes on the radio I'm like oh I saw
these guys live back when I was in
college
I'm in kindergarten speaking of Nirvana
pot is now legal in Washington State I
heard yeah it said spreading around the
cut the first place to make it legal you
remember was Colorado
I remember cuz my friend call me up all
excited he's like then let's go to
Colorado I was like what do you want to
go there for he's like well pot is legal
there I say well I got a better idea
unless you're smoking right here in New
York how about that and we'll close the
door and I think we just might get away
with it all fantasy hey thank you guys
have been great thank you very much
[Applause]
you